From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Okay, okay, all right. Well, here we are.
All right, so this is Emilye Crosby on December 4th, 2015.
And I'm here with Mr. James Miller, Ms. Carolyn Miller at Mississippi Cultural Crossroads in Port Gibson, Mississippi.
We're here with the Civil Rights History Project, which is Crosby sponsored by the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
And with us, our John Bishop and Guha Shankar. And good morning. Thank you for joining us.
Good morning.
Good, Dr. Crosby.
Could you tell us about men and where you were born and growing up when you can start and then?
No, no, no.
Well, I was born, actually at Alcorn State University now, but I was born in the infirmary at Alcorn State University then back in 1953,
because back doing the 50s and before, there were only midwives.
And my mother was having a difficult pregnancy. And my grandmother, who was an educator in the community,
she had a little pool and she was able to get my mom down to the infirmary.
So I was born there. I was the only one in my family actually born in the hospital, so to speak, or with a professional medical person.
Thank you, brothers and sisters.
They were born by midwives. I was the first, so I gave her a little trouble.
That was the only time.
In terms of midwives, Ms. Disney was a pretty bad midwife in this community.
Ms. Dismute.
Jessie?
Jessie.
Yes, Jessie.
She brought me here.
Is that her claim to fame?
Yes.
Who am I going to close?
She was a beautiful midwife.
So I was like, I don't know, unfortunately.
Right. I was playing.
Wow.
But Ms. Disney, probably, everybody in the 50s, she was D1.
She delivered a lot of babies.
Did she just deliver babies for black families?
Or did any white families go to a...
I'm not sure about that.
But I bet she probably did.
Yeah.
Poor black families.
I'm the poor black families.
Yeah.
I probably did.
But I was born here in Florida.
And I was a...
But that was a sheer problem.
I was a...
I don't...
Grand Guff was talking about that earlier.
Okay.
Well, I'm born out there with.
And it was...
Growing up in the 50s and poor kids Mississippi.
I was just running around campus.
I didn't...
I felt like, you know, happy.
It was a little kid growing up here, right?
And then all of a sudden things changed.
You know?
I don't know.
I was like, it's the right movement showed up.
And so you had something to focus on.
Right?
That was different.
And it caused the way society was structured.
You know, white folks said everything.
Right?
Black folks didn't have nothing to run around.
In a lot of cases, you know, living, serving two kind of existence, trying to support their families.
And so it was...
Crazy.
It was a crazy existence.
And there was some crazy relationships.
I mean, black folks and white folks.
You know, I don't think you're talking about a lot, right?
Okay.
Yeah, that was a lot of progress.
Obviously racism was going on too, right?
But poor blacks and poor whites and a lot of cases built coalitions in the community, right?
They supported each other since...
They supported each other's family.
And I think that was kind of like behind the singing kind of thing.
You know, one-on-one kind of relationships, you know?
Not no group dynamics.
But still separate.
And apart.
Can you give an example of how that might work, either with people or just an example of what it would have been like, how that would work?
Well, like my own man, right?
Okay.
I'm just saying, the share in the community, right?
My father was a World War II veteran.
And so he saw a lot of stuff when he went over on the European theater.
And when he came back home, man, he talked a little bit about it.
So it kind of opened up our eyes and stuff, right?
And so some reason other poppers already smoothed.
You know, he would have hairpuff laughing and going on stuff.
So him and his dad had a pretty close relationship.
And he would help pop from time to time.
Okay.
And give him a little money and some stuff, right?
Besides paying him.
I remember when one instance in particular, when I was at an all-corn.
And they were wondering about how I was going to get to school, right?
But I got a little fellowship, but I still needed some money.
I was there, gave him pop the money.
And then pop came to me and said, it looked boy, you know, it was dad giving me this, right?
And then when that happened, right, the movement came.
So you got some dynamics going on, right, between pop and me and dad.
That was just thinking.
You see what I'm saying?
Yeah.
I mean, those kind of things, right?
And so, but pop never scold me.
He never said, boy, don't be in the movement.
He never said that.
And so, I know this dad called pop in and do almost times about me running around here throwing
bricks and stuff, you know, marching and doing all the kind of stuff in the movement, right?
And because those kind of relationships, some black men head with other white men of authority
in the community, right?
It was a paternal kind of relationship, but that was a little bit of respect there too, you know what I'm saying?
So you were just talking about how when you get ready to go to Alcorn, Dan McKay, who is the share of KG,
dad, some money to help you go to Alcorn because they had a working relationship and at the same time,
you're in the movement in the case trying to control you in the movement.
Yeah.
I think what it says too, you know, around my kind of way too is that black men back in the time,
order to try to support their families, they had to jump through a lot of different kinds of hoops and stuff,
you know, and make a lot of psychological, you know, trade-offs, okay, with a manhood, you know,
compromise a lot on their manhood and stuff, right?
Order for a father to family, I think, you know, pop was a good example of that, okay?
And in English, that's one of those, the only other one I would mention very quickly is my head did the same thing,
did a, because pop worked for him too.
And my head was one of the supervisors and leaders in the community, right?
And so pop had that kind of relationship with a lot of powerful white men in this community back in the day, okay?
You know, you know, and about ten months, a slight out of switch, and I think too,
it has to do with class, right, in the community, right?
Because he probably was not, you know, what was the right word?
He went out the bush, one said, you know, okay, he was like a sort of earth kind of person, okay?
Shia Krupp, then you had the educators in the community, black educators, right?
And at that time, business leaders too, because we had thriving black businesses in the community, right?
So there was a middle class, a thriving black middle class that existed in the community, right?
That powerful white folks for the most part interacted with, okay?
Do you think their interactions with that sort of elite class, like the teachers, the ministers, the business leaders?
Is that going to be a different kind of relationship from the one that they have with somebody like your father?
No, they know primarily because he works for them, right?
And they can rely on another worker?
I think the relationship between the middle class and white at that time was hypocritical.
They were trading off each other, they were struggling each other, he goes to a large group.
But I think the relationship between, say, you know, pop and some of the pop-up white folks that he dealt with,
I think it was more honest, honestly, you know?
It was like, okay, well, it was just, there was a human interaction.
It was paternalistic for sure, you know?
But I think it was more genuine.
So I remember interviewing Mr. Mott Hegli, and he talked about actually being out in the fields with the people that were working in this land.
So that they actually have a chance to interact with each other outside, okay?
I'm trying to, I'm a black educator and I'm trying to get money for the school, so I'm thinking what you want me to say, kind of thing.
But they had their hands and everything, they were like school board members, they were like merchants, right?
They were in the banks, you see what I'm saying?
You know, and they were elected officials, it was all interwoven.
You're talking about the black leadership?
Yeah, the leadership.
The white leadership.
Yeah, the white leadership, right?
And so that's why when the blacks and local, local, they're like George and they put on the boycott,
and their argument was, okay, why are you boycotting the merchants?
And got nothing to do with the fact that black folk came vote.
Would you push it?
Thought they all went in the same.
The same people who were running, okay, city hall, and over here in the courthouse,
were the same people who were on the school board, okay, who ran the businesses, you know what I'm saying?
So that's the boycott that started in 66, and it was a whole list of demands there.
And some of the merchants said we got nothing to do with this white boycott, and that's what we had for the good.
Him and the men.
He wasn't outrageous, Mr. and Mrs.
We come and we shop in the business, put somebody in here to work, they look like me.
You know, when you say Mr. and Mrs. what are you talking about?
Mr. and Mrs. Whoever the last name is, the first name, Mr. and Mrs.
You know, when you address me.
When we went in the store, it was boy girl, as opposed to calling it by your name,
or referring to kids working the white kids working in the store,
referred to my grandmother, for example, as girl, as opposed to Mrs. Terransey.
It was just respect.
Basically, lack of respect.
So can you both tell me a little bit more about your childhood growing up?
You mentioned that you felt like really free, a carefree as a kid,
and did you both go up in the country?
I grew up in Hermanville, and my growing up was a little bit different from James,
because I guess my family was considered a bourgeoisie saying,
my grandmother was a school teacher, and my dad was in the Army,
so he was a Korean veteran.
And because my mom and dad were young, my grandmother decided,
well, that was being transferred to different bases,
and she decided, well, you guys are not going to take care with you.
She will stay here because she's got to go to school,
like, wouldn't we school other places, but anyway,
I ended up living with my grandparents, my dad's parents raised me,
and my grandmother's school teacher in Hermanville, for many years,
and my grandfather was a big farmer, and he had his own,
we had about 300, 800 kids of land, and he had workers on the property of black people.
So they had a sort of different relationship,
I guess the relationship like with James was explained,
and it was because they were educated and had money,
they were treated a little bit different than maybe Pops was,
my father-in-law was.
I think it was respect, but not mutual respect, respect for the fact
that they did have an education, and that they had my grandfather,
actually, he did not go to college, but he made it on his own.
And he acquired all of this just from hard work.
My growing up was a little bit different because everything we needed was on the farm.
We ate from there, we ate everything from there.
The only time we came into town to buy from the stores was to get furniture,
sometimes sometimes we bought stables like meal,
things like that, but I had an uncle who was right down the road who actually had his own meal.
We didn't have to do that very much, very often.
Neighbors were like a mile from you, or two miles,
so it wasn't like everybody was right there together,
so we played right there on our farm.
But once we got...
I never had any interaction with any white children.
Actually, the only time I saw any was on school bus going through by the house.
Did you think about the fact that they were going to a different school?
At that time, no.
I had no sense of what was going on because I was kind of sheltered.
But my grandmother always taught me that I was just as good as anybody else.
And then I didn't have to worry about that.
I was a lot of people who told me,
I'm referring to you and saw that as a bitch,
because I have very self-confidence,
so I don't worry about what other people think about me.
And growing up,
I had a lot of responsibility as the oldest.
And my grandfather always told me that you're going to acquire all of this stuff
once we're dead and gone,
which didn't work out that way,
because of other reasons.
But they expected a lot of me and I tried to live up to that.
And I never actually played with any white kids,
anybody other than family or someone,
some of the people who worked for my grandfather, they all children,
and when I went to her middle school,
I went to her middle school from first to sixth grade,
and then I didn't have kindergarten made then,
and then we'd have to come to court Gibson to go to middle school.
And that's when things started to happen here in the county,
the civil rights movement started, you know, began.
It was once that year when we moved,
when I started riding the bus to court Gibson to school.
And then my dad and mom separated,
and I got moved to court Gibson.
So that's how I got involved.
Did either of your parents try to register to vote when you were young
before the movement started or talk about voting?
No, my parents didn't.
My mother was not a radical,
she was kind of laid back, you know,
and I always try to make peace.
People get along and I say,
you know, but she never discouraged us from not being radical.
You know, it was three of us, right?
Dawn, you know, me and Lois.
But she always,
things don't just happen in the vacuum.
I just want to try and say here, right?
Because the experiences that happened within our own family, right?
Okay, my uncle.
And I'm talking, I'm hook it up in a minute, okay?
My uncle, who was a World War One veteran,
I, Uncle David came back,
and he and my grandma,
and he used to talk about friends and the world,
and that kind of stuff, right?
So I'm saying, look here, I'm listening to this year, right?
And I'm saying, you know,
I'm one of about seven, eight,
and like I said, I'm just here free,
ignorant, just running around, just happy, you know?
You know, segregated society, right?
Don't even get no idea how I fit in this separate,
or equal, okay?
Right.
Well, and Uncle David would talk about, you know,
world kind of stuff, right?
She never heard of it.
It was like Star Wars, right?
And then,
Pop, he goes,
and Pop comes back, right?
And he talks about world things, right?
Okay, stuff that changed our,
and we gotta stand.
He is a man who had never left home,
who probably hadn't traveled 100 miles,
in any direction, all of his life,
all of a sudden now he's on European theater.
Okay, he had to be a profound experienced, you know?
And then get back here, right?
And be faced with this hypocrisy, you know?
Get a bus now,
Alabama trying to get back to Mississippi,
coming back to New York, or wherever, right?
You may not make it,
because you got,
and you're black,
but a uniform on,
just for a hit look.
And it's foolishness, right?
And you may not be able to get back home
in the United States.
And I think that part of what,
the white psychic didn't understand,
or didn't appreciate, right?
Is that, you know,
if you're gonna live in a democracy,
okay, and that's what this is, okay?
How can you say that I'm not both participated?
You know, this is hypocrisy.
And it's worse, okay?
And that was the movement we're doing.
The movement was pointing up America's hypocrisy, okay?
And then brothers and sisters who went out
and came back and brought knowledge and stuff, right?
Empowered us over a long period of time, right?
I'm sorry.
Empowered us, right?
And by them empowering us, man.
Okay, it took our psychic to another level, okay?
Did you think about that at the time?
Did they talk about it that way?
Or did you put it together?
No, no, no, no.
Out of the hands, I said,
it fit right.
But what I'm saying is that it was something in the back of the psychic
that was dead, that you remember.
And I guess as you get older, right,
stuff started triggering, you know, you recall.
Talking to both of you had parents who were fathers
that were served in the military,
which took them away from home.
Yeah, we often talk about that because my dad,
and the publications of that.
Yeah, Daddy fought on the front lines and was shell shot.
And when he came back, he couldn't get any kind of services
that he needed, you know?
And we struggled with him with schizophrenia
and just all kinds of medical issues.
Until he died.
Like, you know, dad, he used to know.
And I didn't get as much about what he did there
because he kept it inside.
And we didn't know what was going on with him.
And I remember then he didn't know what was happening
with him because he couldn't talk about it.
But as James was saying,
I got older.
I realized that he, you took a man from small community,
like Claven County,
and taken away across, away over in Asia.
And he's shooting at people.
And he's not even going to know who they are,
why he's shooting them, or any of this.
And then bringing back to the United States
and he treated like he's a second-class citizen
or not even human.
So he shut down.
And it was very hard on the family for a long time.
Dad was on meds until he died.
And we went through some extreme situations
just right here in the county.
And just to talk about a little bit about how white
did help in some sense, Alvin Binder.
Every time, every time, when dad got older,
and it was obvious that somebody had to take care of him,
well, being the oldest,
and it had always been taught, well, it's your responsibility.
I took on dad because Mom and Dad was divorced.
But she never, my mom never, not helped me when I needed it with him.
But he was more responsive to me for some reason.
And whenever he would go off his meds or just drink
and get into an episode,
it was all kind of a real take to try to get him on to the VA.
Well, Alvin Binder, I would go out, please help me.
I need to.
He'd make a phone call somewhere.
I don't know who, but the sheriff would come
and we would have to restrain him.
It was very hard breaking.
But to keep him from hurting himself
or hurting someone else, we did that at least.
What?
You see, that's the humanity I think that cares about.
There's so often missing there.
And I think so often, not understanding communities.
And they said people don't have different agreements about this then and other.
That happens. That's the nature.
But what Allen did was an act of humanity.
Yeah. He didn't have to do that.
I mean, you know what I'm just saying here.
And what was his position in the county at the time that allowed him to do that?
He's just an attorney here.
He's a prominent attorney.
And he was a...
A terrible...
A terrible supervisor.
But I don't know who...
I can't even remember how I even developed a relationship
where I felt I could go to him
and ask him help me. I just did and he did.
Yeah.
What you're saying kind of thing.
I think all this kind of hope ties up, right?
You know, I'm just saying,
like when Bob went to...
to...
to Dan, you know,
and with the...
Mark, okay, and got a little piece of money.
Got a little help to support his family.
I mean, Allen did the same, right?
Yeah.
You said you got as a cream worker.
And do you know if the...
you knew where he served was integrated or not?
Did he ever talk about that?
He didn't.
Yeah.
So I believe it.
I think they integrated some during that war.
So I just wondered if he had mentioned that one way or the other.
Were your grandparents,
did they ever do register to vote or try before the movement, do you know?
Probably not data, Johnny, but I'm sure my grandmother did.
She had her brother,
her virginity.
He was one of the first people to run for elected office.
Yeah.
Any ran for school board?
School...
Let's go to the school board.
Yeah.
So that side of my family was...
active in trying to be...
Yeah.
What was your school like in Hollywood?
Oh, it was all black.
Obviously it was all black.
And the principal was...
if a white senior.
And my grandmother was a second grade teacher.
It was just six teachers because it was first through six.
Everybody there was from the community.
All the teachers lived right there in the community, right in the middle of the area.
I think we had the lunch.
They came from Port Gibson to teach there.
I moved, don't sorry.
What else?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And the classroom sizes were...
About 30 of us probably in the classroom.
We didn't have hot lunches.
We didn't have cafeteria.
We had to bring lunch to school with us.
They brought us milk.
It was a milk man.
You should come and bring...
Just white milk.
And then we had a choice of milk.
What was it for?
Just thinking about that now.
Funny.
The milk man brought milk.
And whatever you had for your lunch.
And there were many children who did not have food.
And my grandmother, because she was...
A lot.
She fed many kids every day.
She would bring enough food.
Because she knew who was going to need something.
And she wasn't the only teacher.
But because I lived with her and I knew how she was about the community.
And about kids.
She took care of all of her children.
Her brothers, children, one of her brothers, Sam Jennings.
He had 12 kids and their mom that early.
So she helped raise them.
And she was just...
Everybody called him...
Mrs. Turnipseed.
But it was Louis Lullaby Turnipsey.
It was her name.
Louis Lullaby Jennings Turnipsey.
She was well known in the community and well loved.
Because of her good nature and her eagerness to help people.
She always wanted to help others who were less fortunate.
And the school was...
It was a community.
I mean, we all...
Everybody got along.
Everybody took care of each other.
And if it was one bad apple.
It was made an example of and everybody else felt in life.
So we didn't have to have in school suspension and all that kind of things that we do today.
Time out, going to court, all that kind of thing.
All you had to do was get the biggest bullet in the school and they got it.
And everyone else got it without the pain.
But it was back then we didn't know that we weren't getting...
Everything that the white kids were getting until...
I do remember getting...
Wondering why our books were so ragged all the time.
And every once in a while there would be...
You might get ten new books.
And everybody wanted those new ones.
And in some classrooms, like it will always be certain kids got those new books.
But even getting a new book, it was probably the oldest edition of whatever it was we got.
I'm sure over here in Port Gibson, the Port Gibson school, at the White School,
they had something even newer than what we got.
But everybody was expected to do the right thing.
We were all taught that to love each other and look after each other.
And to respect one another.
It was...
We were raised up in the classroom just like it would be at home.
And if you got in trouble at school, you had gotten trouble at home.
But that never happened because like I said, it was just one person got it.
And I remember one kid who got it.
Good and poor.
And I don't want that.
So...
I mean, it counts right in there.
I was not the easy kid to get along with in school.
I was always in shit.
Always, man.
And mom just come over there and bake cake and pies and say,
bring it to the guy principal, right?
You know, try to keep my hands out of trouble.
But...
And I remember one more thing.
Ms. Rachel, Ken Lamont.
Ms. Rachel Wilson, Ken Lamont, right?
Okay.
She was a beautiful teacher, man.
And I was in a room, a bad little supper.
And I remember the Rachel telling the story, right?
How she came out, pop was playing, plowing the fields.
And she came out and told me, right?
How foolish is that?
How foolish is that for doing this stuff, right?
And then she said, pop, stop the meal, told her, say, look,
how many, how will do you have him?
She said, I got him, whatever, whatever.
She said, well, when you got him, you do what you need to do
and make him do what he's supposed to do, right?
And when I got him, I'll do what I need to do.
Get up mute, right?
And the Rachel, I would tell her, right?
She would say, and what pop was saying was basically right.
Look, you the teacher, do your job.
I got you back, all right?
He was going to be acting food and playing.
He said, he's been doing that, beat it, that day.
You know what I mean?
You know what I'm saying?
But I think the point is that people were so close, man.
The homeless was so close, right?
And this is all black system.
Back in the, you know, one of my folks in there, okay?
You know, taking care of the business.
Taking care of the business, right?
Educating the kids, right?
Separate or equal, okay?
But at the same time, at the same time,
all these dynamics are going on, right?
Over here, probably straight, you know,
they got the best of everything.
You know, all of the modern stuff, right?
And we know it's good, but we can't get to it.
Okay.
And I think slippage, you know,
makes this quick piece, right?
Is that all the good stuff we had, once we did integrate, right?
We dropped it for the all of that stuff,
which we assumed was the best.
Yeah.
You know?
So, we integrated at the expense of our business.
Of our culture, and our heritage.
And assimilated, totally assimilated.
In a lot of cases, right?
Okay, I don't know if, I mean, you know,
and I'm, you know, I'm saying to me through integration is about,
okay, little bit of your stuff, little bit of master up.
Good stuff, good stuff, good stuff, good stuff.
Yeah.
Bad stuff out, both sides.
All right?
Getting along, right?
And integrate that, and that's what America is about.
Okay?
All culture, we all got some issues, right?
But let's come to the table with the best practices from each culture.
Okay?
It made the community a better place.
You know?
I think that's all still right, moving with saying it.
Okay?
You know, now we made some blunders along the way, obviously, right?
But those growing pains, I think.
Okay?
You know, I don't, I don't, I mean, I know the rich history of Addison High School.
A rich history.
Yeah.
A rich history, man.
A rich history.
I mean, beautiful educators, I mean, the Mae Reeves, or May Mae Reeves, and then, right, of the Martins,
right?
Okay?
You know, the Shafers.
I'm just going to name some of the famines.
Right?
Great educators was in the system, right?
Running the system.
Mr. Dodds and then, Mr. Holtz and all of them folks, right?
And the people just come to mind.
There are a lot of them, right?
Yeah.
So, my premise is this.
It's that we have always been strong on education, black community, right?
They always saw this.
Like Malcolm said, it's our passport to the future, right?
You know, and we, I know them old folks.
Mom and pop, they always told us, I don't know if it's important in this case in the world.
Something happened.
Yeah.
Something happened along the way.
You know, the ball always dropped somewhere, but somebody, it needs to be picked up.
Okay.
So, did you believe about education?
Did you take it to heart when they said?
No.
Not at first.
You know, young and foolish.
You know, and, you know, and again, all of this stuff, right?
That they diagnosed now, their kids have, when they be growing up in school,
were not the stuff.
There might be some stuff that's going on with me.
So, I didn't get all that I was supposed to get.
I know I didn't.
I mean, I missed a lot.
In education.
And then, and a lot of had to do with probably my attitude and the foolishness I was doing and all that.
You know, but, you know, I have to dumb it out.
Okay.
You know, now my brother must have had enough stuff, right?
I just think, lo and firm on his state.
Okay.
You know.
But, but, but, you know, but, you know, with the guy being glory, right?
And I'm saying, we all got to, it's about helping each other.
I guess we're trying to say, you know, you know, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and that was produced.
That was produced as a good community, right?
I mean, look, we're all here on the planet together.
Why can't we just get along?
Wait a minute.
That's what I didn't, that was I didn't, that was easy.
I'm saying, man, I keep going that, I mean, he was a good human being.
Was he perfect? No.
Eight minutes perfect.
He was a good human being.
He could meet you on common ground, right?
He was a key, when I was, when I came back to your man and was trying to make a contribution,
and it's the county administrator, right, to the community, right?
Alvin Binder was a key point in all of that.
It helped him in.
I, it's just you know it.
I remember the day I remember the day.
the day they finally, because it was going through all these changes about hiring names.
It was, he would have two, two of the supervisors was in his corner one day and the next day
it was three and, but they kept putting the vote off.
Is this the first time or the second time?
The second time.
This is when he's applied for the county administrative position.
Yes.
It was like 19.
This was.
It was the second time.
In the late 90s.
Yes.
And I was teaching at the AWWATS and at the elementary school and I was coming through town
and Alvin Binder was a subject of the bank.
It put Gibson Bank.
You know, Alvin Binder's office was right next to the bank.
And I got out of the car and was hated inside the bank and Alvin Binder was coming.
He happened to be coming out of the building, out of his building.
And he, Carolyn, Carolyn, I think, yes.
Hey, Alvin Binder, how you doing?
We got us, got us a county administrative day.
He was just so excited about us.
Oh, great, you know.
But I think I'm sure he genuinely wanted to work with James and wanted to help make
the community be better.
And he was happy to have somebody to help.
He could help an intelligent conversation.
I guess, too, I'm sure they have a lot to do with that.
But it was neutral.
I'm saying, you know, we helped each other.
I'm coming.
Yeah.
All right.
Those people who elected the public office, right, I think it's one of the mistakes that
we made, too, man.
It's that just cause you black.
Okay.
And you run for public office and you get elected.
And you know, you don't mean you can act in the best interests of black folks, white folks,
all right.
Whole folk, young folks, whole folk.
You the act in the best interests of your own self, you know, which is classic Machiavellian
and bullshit.
I'm saying.
And so, you know, you got to hold yourself accountable.
Now, I think that's the lesson that being learned, too, all right.
And you got to forge on hands, right, in relationships.
Okay.
And you have to build on trust and then build on mutual respect for each other, right.
And I come and go.
All right.
I mean, ain't nobody, ain't nobody.
We don't live in a dictatorship.
We live in a democracy, right.
And it means the air by brainless, something to the table.
And you stir it up and you hope it's hopefully, man.
Okay.
You meet, you get some kind of consistency with it.
It takes form.
Okay.
All right.
And if small communities, right, are the laboratories of democracy, that's what they
say, right.
Okay.
If small communities are the laboratories of democracy, right, we here, put gifts on
clay, I don't say this.
We should be a shining example of what the civil rights movement was about.
We should be a shining example of communities working toward the common good and the greatest
good being done for the greatest of know.
And we dropped a ball.
Yeah.
I want to come back.
I know.
I'm sorry.
I know I've got that with me, but I did.
No, I mean, that's important.
Pull up a second.
But can you tell me what, so we're located at cultural crossroads and one of the buildings
is at the corner of Maine on Market and Fair Street.
And can you tell us what Fair Street was like when you were growing up?
Well, that was like coming.
I mean, it was like a carnival.
It was like on the weekends now.
On the weekends.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But Saturday, whenever my granddad would say, can I get rid of we going to town, oh,
boy, get excited because you wanted to ride down the street because you saw all kinds
of people on the streets hanging out, music blasting from the different businesses because
of cheap joints and little grocery stores, little shops and people just would be out
mainly and you could be seeing back then, it seemed like we were there all day.
And it was a festival every Saturday.
You know, it was fun.
It was, but thriving black businesses all up and down the street.
I mean, doing businesses, man.
And like the carnival, right?
I mean, back in the day, you know, in the 50s and the early 60s and stuff, you know,
fast dominoes, avocane.
I was in this come up through here.
Man, they beat out of the day, man.
On the corner down there, it was a two-store building.
Miss La Cain.
The kid, Miss La Cain, remember?
They can't take it.
My grandma used to work downstairs and cook.
In upstairs, they have rooms and stuff, right?
And Miss Keegan was like, she was like half white, you know, high yellow.
Okay?
She called him yellow bone back in the day, right?
And so, a beautiful personality, right?
And cross the street with Dennis Kance.
Dennis Playhouse because Dennis Playhouse.
That was cross 18.
Yeah, it was on 18.
But this was just Dennis.
It was Dennis number two, man.
Basically, where it was.
And then, I mean, Bird had a look at the place, then.
Yeah.
Okay.
Fish market.
Yeah.
I tell you, it's a fish market.
The only white fish that check this out.
The only white business on the street was the fish market.
We was all by Mr. Gladio.
Yeah.
That was the only white business on the street.
On the other street.
How he landed on that street?
Did whites come to his place or was it all black business?
He had this, you know, it's all cage and kind of personality.
You know, he had that kind of personality, right?
And check this out.
Check this out.
No, he was like, oh, yeah, yeah.
He was like, people come on.
They probably came through the week.
See?
Through the week, you know, it was quite, you come to town and go see you.
I have a real estate in the body.
I have heard that from, you know, some of the whites that they never would come off every day on the weekend.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
It was full.
I mean, you could hardly walk on the sidewalk.
I mean.
Which is another issue about perception.
You see what I'm saying?
Enracism.
Yeah.
Okay.
There could not have been a more profound experience by any human being who walked down
fast street.
How many blocks does fast street?
One block.
Not everybody knows what down down.
You see the olden people,
Yeah.
Me.
Be completed in betteronic a little job joint stuff, right, okay.
Bobby "Blue" Bland,
All of them,
John Lee Hooker man,
I mean,
Muddy Waters,
It was down?
Home fast.
That's OK.
Sea flow in the nose.
Take your financial,
Yeah.
Call me your little girl.
Call someone.
But, not just palate,
Jack's beer right I know that
Miller High Life (beer brand)
Country Club
Whole 45
Miller High Life (beer brand) you thought that was your
Oh Miller High Life (beer brand)
Oh you see that's it
I thought I'd only come here
I thought I'd only come here right
That's it
He sure is I'm talking to him
Damn
Anyway
Look at that
It was a thriving community right
Yeah, it was a thriving community
And you weren't
We weren't
Afraid
But we knew
Not to go outside of that
What if we didn't come
What is this street
Fair
It's a mainstream
It knew to turn around
But the corner of Main and Fair
So you didn't go up in the right
By the town
No
I got a mainstream story
Can I see you?
Yeah, that's it
What's here in Main Street?
It's for you
I thought I was
I was in this year
Like I was doing a stupid stuff
And trying to be the class
Richer pride
So I'm coming down
It was supposed to be up here
Because I'm on head
I was on my grandma
At the cafe
I must be in what's happening
8, 7, 8, 7, 8, 7, 8, 7, 8
And so we hanging out there
I was there
Who joined the Warp Young Factory
See man, there's here
He has man, he has man
I was sneaked out the place
I come up here on the factory
Because he was like
Chris on Maine
I mean, me on Main Street
But it was Christmas
It was Christmas right
So all the lights
It was just lit up man
And so I wanted to see what the hell was going on up there
So I'm up there
And I'm coming running down
On the second block of here
I'm running down the streets
And looking all around the stuff
And I ran to this little white girl
And man, damn
When I hit the look
I was accident
And she fell
And she had her dad and her mama
And her little sister with her
And the dad, it was a classic
Six foot some big old dude man
Like two feet, two feet 300 pounds right
I always looked that way
No, no
This guy was a classic redneck
I'm telling you
Oh, that I can do
He made all the stereotypes
And I'm sorry
And his wife was played
And it looked good
And when I knocked it, it looked good
That was something
He grabbed me
And I said, shit, I'm dead
I know he was going to be
I was crying, I was crying, I was crying
And he said, don't you ever look nigga
But jump into my door again
And threw me back down on the concrete
One man pissing on myself
And she said, right?
And so I run my other head back down
To where I was supposed to be
To my grandma
And I went in the back man
And laid down
She said, what wrong with you?
I said nothing
And I just said that man
I never told him about this shit
That shit's getting a hell out of me
I just knew I was dead
I mean, Emmett Till
I didn't know he came so close to listening to me
I never told him
I never told him about this
But that kind of thing speaks in your psychic
And you don't remember
You don't never forget that
You don't get the kind of experience, right?
I could have lost my life
Because I bumped into a little white girl
Back to see the crystal screen
Because I want to see cream cream
And the car
And it doesn't want to see the crystal screen
No, it's the Alan Motor Company
It was right over here, right?
All this wasn't here
There was a big car deal over there
And there was one black candy
It was the candy
It was right there
Where it was the regular candy
Later on
But on both sides of the street
People were parked
And it would be like a showcase of cars
From all of that
I mean, and the bourgeois said of the black community, right?
Okay, now how they would show out, right?
Show their wealth
And they would come park their cars
But on Mayfield you would get a park
Like over here in front of Sherman Front
To come to someplace like that
It was a JC Penis store
No, I didn't pay it
I was just fad in there
Stole right on the next to that
So they would park the cars there, right?
Okay, and let the wagons down
And all the fans would sit in the car
So when you walk out in the street, right?
You would see the couple of street cars
Everyone was on the wire
If bourgeois blacks
Okay, downtown
Forgive me, they're frying cars
You see it, right?
And it was like, "Goddamn. damn
I want to be like that
That's a very right there, you know?
And it was just
It was stuff to do
But you shouldn't lose your life
Yeah, an accident
Because you want to see the lights
Because you want to
Be around folks
Be around excitement and stuff, right?
You shouldn't lose your life
And that's what I was saying
And the irony, the twist to all of this, right?
Is that
Like Tamir Rice (?)
You shouldn't be...
I mean, if you walk down to the store
And get some skills
And walk back to that house to your own neighborhood, your own house
And be dead
And then there's all of them
You see the parallels
Fetch a year later we still doing this same shit
I was resting my cage
It's crazy, it's an accident
And you can multiply that
I mean, the more ladies want it
Just check out those Laquan McDonald
Running away from the person
He running to him
Running away from him
So, I'm just saying
I'm just saying
And so, when those
Ram-moments in history
Put black...
And I know it's my pet pet
But in old Ram-moments in history
When black leaders
When history puts black leadership
In positions of authority
And they are so ignorant
And so arrogant
Not to try
To cultivate
Was in the best interest
And I know it's about it
Who sacrificed in the civil rights movement
So, that was the slap in the face
This is the slap in the face
That's what I'm saying
And these sufferings need to be held accountable
That's unbited
And I know it's a right of the mindset
But these...
I'm suggest this
Is that these civil rights organizations
These white dogs really are
They have to be invisible
On incompetent
Corrupt black leadership
Just like they were
With the clubbers
And incorrect white
When they were in position
What's the difference?
With my name
I know there's people that say
There's a lot of organizing
To cook people in office
To organize and to hold people accountable
That's my point
The movement outside of Port Gibson
Like the Montgomery Busboycott
And until...
Or Martin Luther King
The movement came here
No, no
Yeah
I remember in the TV stuff
I was looking at...
I remember my old folks talking about
You know, him getting killed
I mean, that was...
That was definitely
The TV killer
It was like a ripple effect
And they even looked at it
You know, I guess I understood it
I don't understand
I understood the everywhere I went
Around the black community
People were talking about it
I don't think this
When I became conscious of
More conscious of
Or more fearful
Of...
Not
Of being somewhere that I wasn't
Accepted
For who I was
And being fearful for
If I was outside of my family
Who I knew would take care of me
I would be worried about it
I started to...
People... I started to learn about
Being afraid
You weren't so carefree normal
It wasn't so...
It became out of it
And the killing of Dr. King
I just...
Oh God...
I remember the day it happened
If we were in school
And they made an announcement
And every...
The whole...
You can hear anything
And I don't know why but the...
The whole sky just was dark
And...
I was scared to get on the bus
If it's an option
Pull Gibson
I'd be...
Go back to her room
I was scared to get on the bus
Because I'm thinking
Are they going to come kill all black people
Are they killed Dr. King?
Are they going to kill everybody?
Are they going to kill us all?
You know
So I was scared to go to
Even scared to leave the house
Stay
It's...
It's a heart
Explain being that young
And
Things happening around you
That you have no control over
That you
Have not caused
And
You are being
And you are being targeted because of your skin color.
I don't even know these people.
Why do you want to hurt me?
I've never done anything in these people.
Why do they want, and why am I so different?
What is it about me that I'm not supposed to be here?
Is that a flag back on?
I mean, just pick a flag back on me.
That, the M.O.T.L. killing was the first time that my mom and my grandmother had the conversation
that all people had with their males, their black about what you should and should not
do, what you should and should not be.
I mean, my dad, that is my grandmother, my friends Jackson.
You know, you see what they did to M.O.T.L.
And Jack McDonald's didn't see.
Because Jack, you know, the big picture was in Jack's.
You know, every black person, these Jack, you know, saying, come on.
Even if it was the old, the old one, we all read.
Look at the pictures.
Yeah.
So that way, Jack was so good, right?
Okay.
So, I'm so good at communicating with black people because they knew their market.
They knew their target market, right?
And those pictures, everything, you know what I was saying?
A picture is worth a thousand words.
That was just philosophy.
And when they did that, when they did that, I think it was philosophy.
Because in material, picture, I mean, I mean, come on, man.
In the mud, the courage that she had to do what she did, right?
To say, okay, look, yeah, you can take the picture myself and put it up there.
Because what themselves did was wrong.
Yeah.
And I want the world and no.
You know, I'm saying the courage that they did that.
See how I said, these are untold stories, man, of folks that was in the movement, okay?
They made it, they brought us to where we are.
And that's why I know I'm going to be old and being repetitious, right?
But that's why I'm going back to these suckers who are in positions of authority, right?
And being accountable, okay?
But how many people do that?
I mean, now you're in focus, right?
I'm like, I'm just, I'm just, you know, I wouldn't get people out of the job.
Yeah, just jobs.
It was just jobs.
He was one of the older, older blacks, who had a little land and stuff, right?
I mean, he would give people a deal like that.
He was bailing people out.
He was providing money to get, yeah.
And this is a movement, yeah.
Yeah.
He was one of the first people to register.
Yeah, yeah.
He was there.
I mean, and I'm saying, these kind of, I mean, I'm saying that,
these are the kind of people who shape communities, right?
Who make community good and what have you, right?
Okay.
So the question is always so fundamental to me, right?
Where is that leadership now?
What is it?
What happened?
I mean, I'll go tomorrow.
What?
Oh, damn.
What did you think when your mom and grandma talked to you?
I didn't take a serious.
I mean, I'm lucky.
I mean, I'll go again.
When you were like 12 or 13, 14 years old, man, you know, you, you know, eight and nine.
I was just saying, you must remember myself.
Oh, not by seven.
It was an okay, yeah.
You know, you know, you know, you know, you hear, you know, and you know it's, and you know from
your mom, you ain't stupid.
They didn't even pull your hand out.
I will wipe up.
Okay.
You know, and so, but I will say this though, it kind of brought it home because one night I was
walking home, stayed up when we was in prison for him, but just a walking home across the
bridge, right?
And these were the little CHKs, right?
They were always done of mess too in communities.
There's no untoward so because the CHK was a mixture of the little bad kids, of the upper
white cross, right?
Who couldn't go to public schools and stuff or perhaps, so they sent a little bus up here
to the military academy, right?
Try to get them right.
And so at that time, CHA was our private wife, who was school?
Yeah.
But yeah, yes, yes, yes, yes.
And them and stuff were used to ride around through the community, right?
And at that time, near cars, I was doing a wrist-lew wrist, white boys, right?
And I'm going to probably bring one night from football practice, right?
And you know, hey, dude.
And he threw eight things on my ass, right?
I threw it.
I got shot, shit.
I threw it up.
And then I grabbed it.
And it was fucking the eights, right?
That's a lot of things Jesus said.
I said, shit.
I was about to call it dogs and piss on the fire.
I said, that was over, God damn.
The white foes and kill me, shit.
That was so clear.
I was like, it was the eights, I didn't know what to do.
But he hit me there, so right there.
Oh, it was a fight.
Yeah, but yeah.
Sorry, sorry.
So what's your first memory of the movement here, where it gives him?
Wasn't my point.
You know what?
I'm 60s.
What am I?
I'm low on demand.
60s, I'm the other one, right?
And a lot of stuff, man.
I just had forgotten.
I mean, I was saying, when you talk, when you ask questions,
I don't know.
You had a bad one.
I think when you get older.
Yeah, I guess you started.
Yeah, you started.
You started.
I guess you started going bad.
Yeah, like you started going bad.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But I got here.
Man.
You can imagine, man.
I said, damn, what I'm dead.
So do you remember when you first heard about the local movement
in a random?
Oh, yeah.
OK.
I guess the situation went down state.
Yeah, but it was a bit of a forward head.
The meetings.
Yeah, going to the...
Yeah, the First African Methodist Episcopal Church, Port Gibson MS.
Yeah.
The the NAACP meetings.
So did you find out about it from other kids, from your family,
from seeing people get together?
My grandmother, for me.
My mother's mother.
Yeah.
It was very active in the local the NAACP.
And she would...
Y'all want to go to the meetings?
And we would walk from...
Because by this time, my mother and I totally separated.
And I'm with my mom side of the family.
So we're out on Highway 552.
And we would walk to town.
That's a long walk.
Yeah, we'd walk to town.
And somebody usually would bring us back home.
But we would walk.
I don't want to walk you, too.
Oh, that was 70 miles away.
Yeah.
At least.
It's a huge walk with my mom.
We were walking with my mom seated to the meetings.
And that's where I started.
Were you in the middle of the meeting?
At the time when I...
It was just an outing in the beginning.
And as I got older and started to actually doing things
within the youth chapter, I was involved in helping
the youth to register people to go on out campus and
and helping with voter age.
Because I was considered one of the brighter kids.
And even though I was...
You two were just about 11.
I was going to say this with movement really starts here in about 1966.
So you know that...
I was about that.
Yeah.
I was...
I was double-promoted two times.
So I was way ahead of my peers.
And because of the way I had been raised with my dance parents,
I was always taught to be responsible to take on challenges.
So my grandmother saw the same thing.
My other grandmother.
And come on, okay, let's go to the meetings.
So that's how I got involved.
And they trained us how to go in campus and how to register people.
And that's how I really had them involved.
Would you campus in town?
Or would they care about in the country?
We did town.
Country?
You said they trained you.
Who were you working with?
We had a grant on the four days Cason Project.
But George and them were...
He was a point person.
He was a grad, you know, getting their things together.
He was a leader for the youth chat.
Yes, for the youth chat.
And as George in Milwaukee, yes.
And that's the youth chat of the NAACP.
Yeah, George was...
He was like me and a pretty male organiser.
He really was.
And then with, you know, with dudes like Rudy Shields, you know, but Rudy Shields stood.
I mean, Rudy Shields was shopping in Georgia's skills.
Yeah.
And he had a humble opinion, okay.
Because he was like a mentor.
You know, he would, you know.
Because Rudy Shields was an old organiser.
We're back in Chicago and stuff, right?
We had our whatever.
Yeah.
So, yeah.
But he was a career in that too, I believe.
Okay.
But he had a head on head up.
I always said he had a world perspective on stuff.
Rudy Shields did.
And I think what he did.
And I'm sure, I don't know this for a fact, but I'm sure that there must have been conversations between George and those other guys that George hung out with like, with Joe Zerl and all of them guys, right?
Because they were all, you know, partly the same group basically.
George and Rudy Shields and them.
And I'm sure Rudy Shields and them...
And with their experiences too, you see what I'm saying?
Because all these guys were basically veterans.
Yeah.
That's one of them trying to go with this.
There's this whole cadre of veterans, okay?
It's like a timeline from war, war, war, war, war, two, Korean war, Vietnam war, all the way through.
That was...
For a lack of...
I can say it was milky rise.
It became militant, okay?
And I thought they brought their energy back to their communities.
So they have training and have...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Like with the Deacons?
And they knew strategy.
Yeah.
That's what's going on with the Deacons, right?
They have weapons training.
I remember them guys.
We guns and stuff, right?
So what's the thing about what you remember of the Deacons?
Oh, well, you know, I didn't get to hang with them, but because I was too young.
I remember when I remember that they kept the peace, okay?
And they didn't put up with no foolishness, right?
They were like...
Sort of like black men, if you were, okay?
You know, I think...
Come on, man.
Take this out.
I'll tell you the most things, tell you what I'm gonna say.
Can you imagine 25 or 30 black men at that particular point in time in history walking around with guns
and putting people to business.
You can imagine that you're the date.
When black men.
You know, there's no care for guns, you know what I'm saying?
Okay.
You want to stop this shit?
Go give 25 black men, give them some AK-47s, and let them walk down to me.
And I bet you.
Law of the change.
Nope.
We're gonna do it in a moment.
We'll do something.
Well, in fact, that is actually what happened in Port Gibson.
You remember that?
Did you know how that did the movie?
So when Rudy Shields and George Henry and Julius Warner,
when they were organizing the dance and the deacons and they were carrying the weapons,
Dan McCay came to them and wanted to de-escalate and said basically the board of the city council
was gonna do a law that you couldn't carry down in public.
And they were like, well, you know, we're not the ones that started it.
I didn't know that.
And Dan said he was gonna put everybody, put the guns away.
And so Rudy Shields said, well, we'll give it a try.
That's a story.
Okay.
But so, yeah, what was it like as kids to see these black men carrying guns in the community?
I feel protected.
I feel good.
I mean, they have like superheroes.
I never seen them like this.
I mean, they get in there.
You have the black heads on it, right, right.
Even like the homophias still, you know, no, no, no, no,
they'll take those cops off the campus.
I said, he get in there.
He's just bad.
I'm just talking about the little revenue they beat.
I mean, they worked, right?
They didn't beat with baseball, bad.
It was psychological, but it was dehumanizing too.
But where they would do, right?
They would preach to themselves, don't break the boy cut.
Those boy cut.
Hey, revenue.
Who was his man?
Damn, I can't think of his name.
And Mr. Davis?
Oh, I went there with him.
No, oh, the revenue.
The revenue.
That they beat his butt.
What was that?
I can't think of it.
Even the little chopped fat guy, right?
Dark skinned it.
Okay.
But he was, but he was, but he was, I don't think he was.
I mean, he had no good understanding.
Yeah, that's what I was saying.
I don't think, other people would always say, top either, right?
But you know what I'm talking about, right?
You know, so you know I ain't lying.
Okay.
The little cut.
So, this Brad back here on the street, fast street.
All right.
You know when it's over two or three times, right?
So, it's a little bit, we don't get that solid, right?
Right.
Well, I don't know where he was.
We were going to get in the night, right?
So, he would do, I don't know.
Everybody did do it there too.
So, he would do it.
It's okay.
And the jaw is in there.
And pludy.
Okay.
And then who else was in there?
His name was Wendy?
Wendy.
Yeah.
One or the other.
I guess I got that.
So, they grabbed him down there and then added on there, right?
And they had a big old limb, man.
It was like a switch, right?
They took him back in that Alvin Binder behind King Shushan, pulled his clothes down and shit, right?
And tore that ass up.
T tore that ass up.
He'd come out there hooping in Holland with his pants down.
And Wendy, we already told you how crowded, fast street be.
And this was like on the weekend.
This was like Saturday night or something, right?
Man, look, that dude ain't never broken for that no more.
Nobody else, bro.
And nobody else.
So, did you see that?
I saw that.
I saw that in my own.
My grandma's cafe was Red Cross Street.
Okay.
And then it was a little Alvin Binder.
Well, across my grandma's cafe was King's Shushan.
But at that time, it was like a two-story building.
And it burned down.
And the present one that's there now is the one that was there.
But back then, it was like two-story.
It had to walk up.
Milleness, yeah?
Okay.
And it was a little Alvin Binder in there.
And this is why they took it in between the Alvin Binder.
Between the Alvin Binder King's Shushan and Freshman.
It was a little Alvin Binder in there.
And they threw him up in there and tore his ass up.
And he'd come out there and rip him and run.
And hear it up.
From this way to that tree one.
I mean, how you forget how you don't not remember that.
I mean, that, but man, I must have laughed by that shit for about 10, 15 years.
I mean, you know, it was the standard, you know, laugh in the movements.
Yeah.
Well, yeah, everybody heard about it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
In the black of you.
In the black of you, right?
And...
Did somebody burn them white?
I can't.
Yeah, what that made.
I'll figure it out during the break.
Okay, okay.
But so, and you said breaking the boycott.
So, so give us the context for the boycott and what was going on.
So, what was the boycott?
The boycott was put on the white clothes who were the merchants, right?
Because they were the same people who were the politicians.
Yeah.
And what was the whole thing about breaking the boycott?
How did that work?
What was the setup in town?
You were in a store.
Yeah, you couldn't know in a store.
Not buying a thing, but like people stay out of the stores.
Yeah.
Don't purchase anything from any white merchants.
And the Deacons had watched people watching.
You know, you might not have seen the Deacons, but the Deacons could see you.
Okay.
And they had a paper.
And they put out with everybody's name on it.
And they're so glad you threw the community through the community.
Yeah.
So, they're back new.
If your name was on that list, you could probably you don't get a visit from the Deacons.
You still got a little bit.
Yeah.
And you think that that was how big a factor was that in keeping people out of the stores?
I think that it was a true factor.
But I think for the most part, people didn't break it.
Yeah, people.
Everybody was tuned into the town.
Yeah.
You know, they knew, I mean, people as a white open, they saw the atrocities there were happening there.
Come on, we got King, Keel, Luke Keel.
We got a kettleboys, right?
We got a mayor.
I mean, the freedom summer, always going on.
All that was going on at the same time.
Yeah.
So people named Inid, they basically shit.
The majority of the people were going to honor the boycott, in a way.
That was for the hard hits.
Okay.
We're not playing.
We're serious about this.
You know, we don't need no cons.
And everybody was able to say earlier, right, by the bullet, you put, that's something in check.
Yeah.
Everybody's falling in line.
And so I know you're a little bit, you, you were a little handed school, apparently.
Well, I love it.
She was catching up with you fast and serious.
She just about beat you out.
So you remember some of those early meetings that you've told me about.
Oh, yeah.
What are the, uh, okay.
What does it mean?
Okay.
One in particular, I remember, I was, I was, I was, is when, how rooted she was a master organist in terms of,
I mean, I had to love to watch her, man.
I mean, I, obviously now, hands like, I, I have more appreciation for it.
Not much so then, right?
I didn't know you were the man.
I do, right?
Okay.
But how, how he could, how he could, uh, how he developed leadership.
So the big meeting down here, right?
And, uh, people were down there in the neighborhood.
And so, a lot of discussion was going on about what the problems were and what need to be done.
And blase, blase, blase, and blase, and blase.
Is this the meeting at the end of the year?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, me church, right?
Okay.
And Camerrill Williams was one of the people that was at the meeting, right?
Like, Camerrill Williams was also a part of the bourgeois class, right?
We talked about earlier.
And he was a big time, uh, scared to answer.
Maybe the chief was something to think down at all times.
You know, he ran far.
Sure.
I'm sure it ran far.
Right, we were just not a whole story, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Uh, so, he was down at the meeting, and, uh, I don't know, so a lot of the black men, and mostly they were, uh, the bourgeois class.
Okay.
They were like, well, working class.
So, like, you know, people like, like, say, like, Louis Maggum, right?
Okay.
Who was like a, uh, uh, wait for the city.
I, you know, they, you know, they were there.
Boston Barber, who worked for, uh, Alamo, the company, right?
Okay.
You know, dumb kind of people were there, right?
And so, as they were, uh, people were talking,
everybody was saying, and who they were looking to say, he was those stuff out there, right?
And said, well, what was y'all think about this?
What do you want to do about this?
And somebody was respond, right?
And so, Camerrill would start to respond.
Camerrill Williams, and then,
rooted through one quid that Alamo and the question was, right?
But they like, kind of, did that to root, right?
With Camerrill's response, did, it's kind of knocked him back, right?
And Louis Paul's for a minute, he said, hey, you come on up here.
And from that point on, man, that dude was a leader.
And this community.
I saw that with my own eyes, man.
Materialized.
I said, this is, you know, but I'm saying, he was always paid to another level
within the civil rights movement.
Now, whether or not he was a genuine, I don't know, you know,
a tab or tail, okay?
Well, the history would speak to that, right?
Well, he was sincere enough.
But he ran, and it was the first one to run for sure.
Yeah.
In the count, okay?
And he ran in the 60s and 67 in that first election after the
voting rights act and the voter registration drive.
Yeah.
So, Rudy Shields Shields, who was Rudy Shields Shields?
Can you describe him for people that wouldn't have any idea who he is?
Someone that you would not, if you saw him walking down the streets, right?
You wouldn't really wouldn't, you wouldn't, I mean, he wouldn't catch your attention.
You know, he was like a, he could blame in, like a chameleon, you know?
And he always came on board.
What I can remember.
But he came from Wayne.
But he came, well, I think his home was the end of the city, but not mistaken.
I think he's already from the end of the city, by way of Chicago, because he has some people in Chicago too.
And he's some of the end of the after all this.
Yeah, after all this.
Yeah.
He was from Ohio, in Chicago, here.
But I never understood a lot about his history, you know, about where he came from and all that, right?
Just the interaction when he came here, right?
But he always seemed to be somebody who was very bright, okay?
Seen to be committed to the community.
And I saw examples of that, okay?
He wasn't kind of present.
Like some, I saw who came, who told it was about their own self and that.
You know, what could I do for me?
You know, how can I capitalize on this personally, right?
He would seem to be a very genuine, you know?
I never saw that.
I mean, you know, not that we all should die of purple, but I think he died of purple, man.
Basically, right?
Okay.
And, you know, he's just a lot of bad bricks and I guess in life, you know, in the end.
He didn't end up, you know.
So all good men, you know, don't get the jitter award.
But really, but be that as it may.
And I'm just a question.
I think he was a, he was a godson for this community.
He really changed.
I think changed the political progetaries of this community, okay?
By the organized skills that he brought and how he empowered other people, okay?
Who lived here?
He got shit done by doing it through other people and empowering people.
Yeah, through the local people and empowering the local people, okay?
All right.
Which I always thought was a beautiful model, man, for community development, okay?
You know, you know, that's, you know.
I mean, everybody is sharing in the wealth of the community, right?
Okay.
Then there's seem to be like there's less fiction, there's less racial tension.
You know, so, you know, if I'm white or I'm black and I'm living in this process, right?
If I don't want to be able to say something about it, I ain't got to do it.
I go to parents or go to Europe or go to Africa or whatever, right?
You got those kind of options, you know.
But the ideal thing would be in Utopia, right?
Yeah, and you know, you know, you know, you know, you know, I'm concerned about racism, but I really don't have a lot of time to spend on it.
You know, I'm sorry.
A few years I got led up, you know, I'm about trying to build some bridges and if you don't want to build them, that's cool.
To leave me alone.
So that meeting, what else do you, I mean, I think that meeting was, it was one of the first meetings right after Rudy Shields started organizing the community.
And how did whites respond when Rudy Shields Shields and then Charles Evers followed behind Rudy Shields and they were working in Claiborne?
How did the white community respond to that?
They got, they considered agitators.
And coming in and stirring up trouble between the blacks and the whites.
But you know what was unique about this place, about Mississippi, in relationship to that?
I mean, the whites here, the clockers, man, they put them in check and they went another way that white citizen council stuff.
You know what I'm saying? I mean, they took the two-club clan model out of the street, in terms of Bull Connors and all of that.
I think they learned something from what had happened. Some some way.
And they were like, yeah, look, the position is right, that we take it. But we got to clean up our act.
We got to go in and we came, it can't be worn on worn confrontations, right?
We have got to figure out how we make the institutions put these in check.
So, what they started doing, right? They started infiltrating boards, the Democratic Party, the Republican Party,
where they took them over at the precinct level, organized these lawyers, again, back to Alvin Binder, right?
Good human being. These lawyers in these different communities, right?
They started doing all kinds of little stuff, right? Like, how do you think Alvin Binder High School got built?
Alvin Binder High School got built because they didn't want no black folk coming over to book them high school.
That little man, little drape. He was one of the architects next year.
I didn't got no document over this, Emily. Okay. But it was genuinely, it was genuinely a point of conversation.
Among them brothers out hanging out with listening to, that's what went down.
Okay. Oman, Oman Drey was very instrumental behind the scene doing some things.
You see, right? Balls with Carp the Club, case and point. You see what I'm saying?
And these were the compromises. Okay. So, we just have to get new school.
Yeah. And that was in the 1950s? Yeah, we were. Yeah.
So, that's a brown, right? Yeah. So, I'm saying, right? And so, and that was when I was a strategy, they were putting play.
But my point is, okay, so the club, White folk, it depends on where you were in the state.
Okay. But here, I think the response was more institutionalized as opposed to 101 racism.
You know what I'm saying? Yeah. Can you tell me about the Human Relations Committee and the the Bi-Racial Committee?
What's the... Yeah, you don't understand something.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I think, you know, I, I, I, I, I, I, you know, you asked me that question 20 years ago, I would, I would, I would have a, you know, but as you get older, right?
You kind of reflect on stuff, right? You know, you, you melt in yourself. I hope, hopefully.
It was the Bi-Racial Committee. It was the set of Black folk that White folk have picked. Yeah. Okay. That's what I'm saying.
They became most sophisticated in terms of trying to keep separate but equal in place. Yeah.
So, we're gonna pick up some handpick, right? Okay. And we put one, two, over there. They're gonna, we'll try to do the right thing, right? Okay.
They're following me, right? Make it look good, right? And I think Rums Johnson was a man that was caught up in change.
He could pick up what side of the fence he wanted to be on. And a lot of, a lot of Blacks, or the Buiwai class ended up like this.
You know, you know, and White folk played along with it and it was still an advantage.
And, you know, it's unfortunate, but that way, what?
I make it like that.
So that meeting at the First African Methodist Episcopal Church, Port Gibson MS, I think my understanding from talking to people is that that's, that there was sort of a showdown that night that the Human Relations Committee was trying to encourage the Black community to do one thing and really shields was there representing the NAACP and Charles Evers and trying to advocate another.
And you must have been like a high school student. I was, I was, I remember the incident, but obviously I don't remember all the dynamics in behind the scene and what was going on.
But I remember, I remember what you talking about. I remember it, man. But, you know, here again, reflecting on it back now. Now, okay.
It was obvious that with, with three competing interests, interests in the room at that time. Okay. And, that was, man. That dude.
You know, but you can say what you want about Evers. I have, I have a great respect for Charles Evers, right? I honestly do. You know what? Because he always told you what he was.
He said he wrote it. Up here. He said that. He said it, but he wrote it. He said, look, I'm against it. Out of Chicago. I don't think like my brother. My brother ain't me. I'm telling, we do. He, he, he, you know, now, here again, in some quarters, you say that people look at you like you crazy. Well, I didn't say that. He said it. Really, but.
And so now as that relates to what was happening here in Claiborne County, right? Okay. And then he gave me a shot. That was him saying you see the sophistication that was at play. That white says in counsel and then, right? And all of them big time lawyers.
And then he said, this point, this racism stuff goes all the way up to the state level. Okay. So deep people talking to Evers. Obviously, I think it should be bad. I had been some conversation going on between Evers and them people had to be about this is way down there and pogos. And how we deal with it. Okay.
Premier case in the country. Right. So this whole issue of whether or not blacks have the right to use economic sanctions. Okay. Against those who are pressing them.
And you talk to hear about the NAACP v. Claiborne Hardware Co. 458 U.S. 886 Co. Yes. So that was filed by the white merchants 69 to try to stop the boycott. Yes. And the NAACP. Yeah. Port Gibson.
Port Gibson. That would be a demo to that. I think that was when you guys were talking about when you would ask in the question about the at the church, the meeting at the church.
I think the discussion was something about that boycott.
There might have been another one because the meeting there was one meeting that was in late 65. And so and it was my understanding is the biracial committee.
White's found in a biracial. Yeah. Yeah. Like section of the human relations committee. They were trying to keep Evers and the NAACP out of Port Gibson. Yeah.
So did you ever see Rudy Shields Shield in action? Like the only time I saw him actually. Well, action. The most profound thing.
It was a time when Emerson Davis had to go and it was going to shoot him and he walked up to him and took the gun out of his hand. And the one other confrontation around here with the guy that had to find the store. Those are two times I really saw him.
Can you describe those incidents for people that are known? Well, I mean.
So why is here had obviously Geek must have. Davis up. (to) kill Shields. Okay. He had a gun. They say white post against them. But they say I don't know.
I do know this. I know Rudy Shields here. I know what the gun look like. And the sucker didn't go. So it must be a must game. I get it. He sees with him or he would know. I don't know. But he didn't go and go out and see if walked up to him.
And Rudy Shields was honest and I would. The biggest lot of the guy was standing around right cause it just happened about nothing. And it was confrontation. I don't know what that conversation. What they where they have a prior to because I was there.
And I I it happened right down here. I believe it was right. When I mistake on the corner. My mom. Okay. Yeah. I believe it's confrontation. Anyway.
He walked up to him. Rudy Shields did walked up to oh man Davis man and took the gun out of there. And then they arrested him and took him off. You know what?
Not going to. Right. Davis was right. Oh, they were right. It was black. They was black. Oh, he was well. What they like with the term in the community. I mean, that would. Yeah. I mean, why he's. But he went that way. And the other guy was the guy that owned the furniture store.
Really just don't. Okay. I know, Jones Jones. Yeah. Jones. Yeah. Yes. Who I got feelings in with today here.
Hear of. He he walked up to him set something to him. I don't know what it was. Another face to face. one-on-one confrontation.
Grace Rudy Shields. That. Congratulations.
I remember that taking place. Right. Yeah. Those are going to come back.
What was I like for you, young person to see that happen?
I mean, you know, you guys stand and look, okay.
When you look at me, all your life, and you see black men talking to white men, like that, as an equal, up in their face, man.
That's...
No.
And then, you know, confrontational.
You know, I mean, that's...
That sticks in your psyche.
You know, give you a little balls.
You may not...
But I can do that too.
But, you know, I mean, but we see, you gotta take it in...
Historical context, right? You know, in the time.
You know what I'm saying? You know what I'm saying? Okay.
And at that time, in history, man, I mean, you know, that kind of behavior on black folks, you know, I heard of...
I mean, the consequence with this.
Yeah.
Okay. Now, you could do it, but you're gonna be dead.
You have any memories of Rudy Shields?
No.
Just, you know, I remember him up talking in meetings and that.
Can you all describe mass meetings, what they were like, the people who never had the good fortune to be part of it?
Let me say what they were saying about Rudy Shields, man.
And that thing is, I just wanna say, I want to make a part of it.
I really honestly hope, man, that history records the contribution that Rudy Shields made to this trouble.
I'm serious.
I mean, unsung hero.
I'm sorry, but I'm not a hero.
Okay.
The meetings were...
The mass meetings were exactly that.
Man is the meeting.
There would be people...
When we started going to the First A.M.E. Church, that church was the biggest church in the community at the time, black community.
And it would be full.
The outside of the church, people...
We'd be standing outside trying to get in.
And so, the one day had to let the windows up and stuff where people could hear.
Because, you know, we didn't have loudspeakers.
And Deacons standing as guard.
Yeah. Deacons standing as guard and make sure everybody was safe.
And then freedom songs coming out of the rafters.
You could hear them.
Yeah.
But, you know, mostly will.
I mean, I hear that little soldier in there, you know, who'd been in the Holocaust.
Her and Dali, you know, don't just...
Just the highway.
Yeah.
And, I mean, they were singing their hearts out.
Bill, bro.
I'm just saying, you know, it was like...
It was like Sweet Honey in the Rock.
You know?
It was profound.
It was...
It was a time that...
I mean, I am so glad that I lived in revolutionary times.